[Música]
hola qué tal bienvenidos acá a este
canal en las américas café de este
viernes 20 de septiembre como de
costumbre todos los viernes aquí
puntuales para esta cita semanal con
todos ustedes
hoy tenemos varios invitados bueno pero
primero leonora chat pan y leonardo 15
días buenas noches
y tenemos decía varios invitados hoy uno
de ellos con el que vamos a comenzar
este programa ustedes muchos de ustedes
lo conocen ya porque fue nuestro colega
en la sección latinoamericana durante
muchísimos años sobre todo en la época
de la onda corta
bueno es martín movilla bienvenido
martín hola pablo hola leonora hola leo
cómo están todos un saludo por supuesto
para los oyentes y bueno pues martín
movilla que desde hace ya cierto tiempo
yo diría varios años no está trabajando
ahora con la televisión francesa de
radio canadá y más particularmente está
con un programa de investigación
periodística que se llama arquette y la
razón por la cual lo invitamos a martín
acá este viernes es para que paraná
sobre esas bienes culturales importantes
para servicios de cultural y para que
pague la cerveza entonces hay que
invitarlos a ver el programa no pero la
verdadera razón es que este jueves 19 se
presentó en la televisión de radio
canadá en este programa de investigación
periodística aunque ter
un programa en el cual martín estuvo
trabajando él es el realizador de hecho
de ese programa y sobre todo bueno que
hizo con todo el equipo de anged que
bastante grande es un equipo bastante
grande aunque bueno por supuesto cada
emisión se trabaja a parte digamos de
alguna manera en esta emisión pues por
supuesto hay editores camarógrafos y un
periodista look sharp tran y yo que
fuimos los que llevamos a cabo esta
investigación a investigación de largo
aliento sí bueno pues de eso vamos a
hablar del síndrome de la habana del
famoso síndrome de la habana todos
ustedes muy probablemente escucharon
hablar de estos famosos ataques
acústicos no del cual padecieron
diplomáticos canadienses y
estadounidenses basados en la habana y
bueno pues eso pues yo quisiera comenzar
contigo martín como como surgió la idea
de hacer este programa que vimos ayer
que de hecho te quiero felicitar es muy
bueno gracias pero en realidad hace ya
dos años en el 2017 cuando se comenzó a
hablar de este tema nos inquietamos nos
preocupamos porque se hablaba ya de
canadienses que serían afectados en
total oficialmente según el gobierno de
canadá 16 canadienses entre ellos
diplomáticos y sus familias habrían sido
afectados por este fenómeno que llaman
el síndrome de la habana comenzamos a
hacer gestiones pero nos interesaba
mucho dos cosas por un lado la versión
cubana de esta situación porque porque
en medio de todo esto hay muchos temas
geopolíticos intereses el tema de pensar
que ocupa o de pronto un aliado cubano
rusia o china pudiese tener un arma
diferente y desconocida y decir muy
diferente y desconocida porque al
principio que se habló mucho del tema de
ataques acústicos se hablaba de que hay
armas acústicas existen esas armas
acústicas nosotros las mostramos en los
cubanos estamos al tanto de lagos no
sólo no estaban al tanto sino que además
se necesita recursos presupuesto y las
armas que se conocen acústicas o de
microondas que son las otras señaladas
en ambos casos armas que utilizan ondas
son armas muy costosas pero también muy
grandes
entonces había la necesidad pensar que
existía un arma que nadie conoce yo creo
que la mejor definición nada a uno de
nuestros personajes en el programa doc
phelps es un neurólogo muy conocido que
trabaja para la revista science que ha
hecho el seguimiento de este tema muy
respetado y decía para un arma
extraordinaria un hecho extraordinario
con consecuencias extraordinarias por
qué porque los diplomáticos tendrían
lesiones cerebrales importantes pero la
gran mayoría no tendrían lesiones en el
oído entonces si por ahí entró el ataque
como el oído está bien y el cerebro está
mal decía entonces la conclusión que él
decía era un tema extraordinario con un
arma inexistente o extraordinaria con
unas consecuencias extraordinarias
demerita es decir exige pruebas
extraordinarias en este caso no las hay
decía todo esto nos llevó a buscar
personajes vimos casi que la vuelta al
mundo estuvimos con gente en nueva
zelanda más uno de los más grandes
especialistas del tema de psicología de
masas porque se habló en un momento de
histeria colectiva
era que había una invención de la gente
y por supuesto tuvimos un acceso también
único exclusivo a la investigación
cubana estuvimos con los cubanos en el
terreno con los policías y los
científicos que investigaron en cuba
para tener también otro punto de vista
el de cuba que a veces se deja de lado
por temas políticos etcétera y tuvimos
la digamos un abanico de posibilidades y
terminamos con un tema que era la
segunda parte que nos interesaba que
cuando comenzamos en 2017 no existía y
que en curso de la investigación se dio
fue que el gobierno de canadá pidió a la
universidad dalhousie en halifax en las
marítimas canadienses hacer una
investigación científica con todos los
afectados canadienses esa investigación
no había salido nosotros plantamos ayer
en exclusiva como conclusiones y
concluye dicen ellos que si hay daño
cerebral lo cual es importante porque
para las víctimas canadienses era muy
importante su credibilidad el hecho de
que los acusaran de histeria colectiva
les molesta y les molesta si así lo
sienten ellos y dicen además que nadie
los había revisado para hablar de
histeria colectiva sin ningún psicólogo
había estado hablando con ellos
que ha hablado del tema histeria
colectiva hay que decir que grandes
medios del mundo en new york time in new
yorker 'vanity fair' hablaron del tema y
de hecho los científicos que
entrevistaban se inclinaba más por ese
por esa explicación lo que tiene el
informe de la universidad dalhousie que
es interesante es que confirma que hay
un problema físico una lesión cerebral
real hay un caso que viene a probar eso
y que digamos no no se atreve uno decir
en los reportajes destruye pero que pone
un poco en el filo de la navaja la
teoría de la histeria colectiva la
psicosis de más de un perro de uno de
los afectados canadienses un perro
pequeño que cambio de comportamiento en
cuba y que murió no tienen que nacer
porque el perro se puso muy agresivo y
vivía como medio loco y al hacerle la
autopsia se dan cuenta que las mismas
lesiones que los humanos en el cerebro
entonces dicen bueno el perro no sufre
de histeria colectiva elige psicosis de
matar a quien lo puede convencer de
aparte que una historia de una psicosis
colectiva te deje un daño cerebral
legítimo eso es es complejo y bueno lo
del perro viene a confirmar
importante la segunda parte muy
importante del informe de la universidad
dalhousie es que es un informe serio
sopesados en intereses geopolíticos muy
científicos y ellos avanzan una posible
causa que es la fumigación al papel
dicen agentes neurotóxicos que habrían
causado las lesiones cerebrales estos
agentes de euro tóxicos de los que se
habla son agentes que utilizan la
fumigación que pasó en la época y
tendría el sí por eso eso así que la
teoría tenga mucho asidero y pueda ser
muy válida no nosotros por supuesto como
periodista no nos casamos con ninguna
las presentamos todas pero esa la
presentamos como la última que existe
porque al hacer una exclusiva nuestra no
había salido nadie la conocía y es de
alguna forma pues tienen su implicación
para el gobierno canadiense para el
gobierno canadiense tiene implicaciones
políticas implicaciones geopolíticas de
alguna manera viene a destruir la idea
de un arma de alguna manera pone en
entredicho el tema de la psicosis de
masas es y pone en entredicho lo
anterior pues una explicación mucho más
sopesada mucho más puesta en tierra si
se quiere y es el hecho de que en cuba
entre 2016 2017 y 2018 hubo grandes
campañas de fumigación para luchar
contra el cica el gobierno cuáles son
grandes fumigaciones casa por casa y en
las calles en todas las ciudades del
país y muy particularmente en la habana
en el sector donde vive la mayoría de
los afectados nosotros fuimos a cuba y
ahí estuvimos hay un jardín inmenso que
también fue fumigado pero además el
gobierno de canadá como el de eeuu y los
otros gobiernos contrataron sus propias
compañías de fumigación para las
residencias de los funcionarios porque
son territorios o con si se consideran
como pertenencias extra territoriales de
los los cuales no tienen acceso
así que encontraron sus propias campañas
de fumigación que dice el reporte de la
universidad dalhousie dice que la
sobreexposición el exceso de exposición
a estos pesticidas podría ser la causa
de las lesiones cerebrales porque el
gobierno fumigó y cuba- fumigó entonces
el gobierno fumigó en ocasiones hasta
cinco veces más que el gobierno cubano
su mirada entonces parece que hay una
exposición permanente constante durante
un periodo tiempo muy largo a estos
pesticidas lo cual sería pues una
explicación lógica dicen ellos porque
fueron las embajadas y las residencias
de los diplomáticos las que fueron
fumigadas entre otros por el mismo
activo
yo tendría una pequeña pregunta martín
estuviste en habana vos conocés
físicamente cómo están las embajadas me
imagino que la embajada canadiense y la
estadounidense están juntas o no lejos
porque lo que pasa con las otras
embajadas porque no hubo los mismos
casos esas son las preguntas que quedan
después de este reporte hay dos cosas
que podrían tener relación es que
nosotros no tenemos la respuesta tampoco
y es la primera hay un caso muy
particular de por qué los canadienses
afectados pusieron una demanda contra el
estado canadiense 28 millones de dólares
una de las personas que se encuentra
allí con las que nosotros hablamos las
víctimas vivían en una casa que cuando
uno está en el terreno tiene dificultad
para entender es una casa que queda
literalmente metida en una y se quiere
rodeada completamente
la embajada británica y las residencias
de los empleados británicos esta persona
habría sido afectada pero nadie en el
entorno fue afectado se podría venir a
justificar el hecho porque su caso de
unas obligaciones que en el otro no lo
hubo pero es raro que una persona
resulte afectada haciendo una isla en la
mitad de un mar de embajada y de
residencia pero sí pero si la receptiva
mos la embajada cadencia si fue fumigada
brilla y ya esa residencia también es
decir eso dice el informe de la
universidad dalhousie pero es raro la
embajada de eeuu al canal quedan lejos
no quedan cerquita son las residencias
donde vivía la gente donde se presenta
la mayoría de los casos hay que decir
que contrario a la creencia popular la
mayoría de los casos de canadienses
afectados no escucharon nada
y eso es importante porque hay que
recordar que esto está historia comienza
cuando eeuu dice estamos bajo ataque
nosotros lo contamos en el documental y
posteriormente entrega la prueba 'reina'
una grabación que habría obtenido una de
las presuntas víctimas de
estadounidenses curioso porque siempre
tienen pruebas los estado en ese todo lo
bien que acústico o las palabras ataque
acústico quien sostiene la teoría de los
ataques acústico durante mucho tiempo es
el gobierno de eeuu los cuales comienzan
por supuesto a investigar este tema
canadá es mucho más parco no asegura una
cosa ni la otra de hecho todavía en la
respuesta oficial que nos llegó muy
tarde del gobierno canadiense frente a
este reportaje dicen que el tema sigue
abierta hasta que no acaben
completamente lo cual es lógico también
aro porque tampoco hay tantas versiones
que es importante no puede dar ahora
binaria exactamente pero lo que sí hace
es eeuu hasta este momento no ha habido
ninguna reacción oficial si se quiere lo
que uno ve en los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses que retomaron lo que
nosotros hicimos en gran parte es que
hay reacciones de funcionarios que dicen
anonimato otros en privado dicen que
todavía falta mucho para que eso sea
cierto nos entendemos que cuando hay
procesos jurídicos también en curso hay
que tener mucho cuidado con lo que uno
dice con lo que los estados dicen por la
responsabilidad si llegase a hacer si un
estado acepta si canadá dice si estamos
de acuerdo a la fumigación entonces
canarias una responsabilidad directa
extra jurídicamente su propia red
sensorial lo cual le afecta
jurídicamente porque pagar mínimo 28
millones justifica la demanda que son
los diplomáticos es hay toda una
cantidad de historias pero digamos que
lo que nosotros queríamos era poner
sobre la mesa todas las hipótesis
estudiarlas y analizarlas con los que
saben de esto no somos científicos y
buscar cuáles son las respuestas más
concluyentes lo que nosotros en el
reportaje logramos de alguna manera
identificar es que si hay lesiones
cerebrales en las víctimas lo cual es
importante porque muchas ocasiones y
criticó la posibilidad que no existiesen
esas lesiones o el origen mismo de ellas
es que fue porque estaban más viejos es
porque no sé qué porque hay muchas de
esas lesiones que uno tiene por la edad
entonces se justifica a través del
informe de algunos y los otros informes
hubo uno de la universidad pensilvania u
otro la universidad de miami que ya
decían que había lesiones
científicos de dalhousie trabajaron con
investigadores de otros país no es una
investigación ciento por ciento
canadiense son 27 investigadores después
de que lo hicieron después de ser
publicados también lo pusieron a
disposición de toda la comunidad
científica internacional cuba por
ejemplo su reacción oficial hasta ahora
ha sido que eso no explica todo pero que
es una muy buena pista de partida para
una investigación conjunta porque además
si llegase hacia la fumigación cuba
tiene muchas cosas que responderse a sí
mismo más que a canadá o eeuu esté
haciendo turismos han están allí en la
fumigación es que han detectado cubanos
quejas de cubanos por el mismo problema
hasta este momento no pero no hay que
olvidar que la investigación cubana
aunque miro todas las pistas posibles la
investigación con hasta la central la
denuncia un ataque
ahora tiene que ir a mirar todo lo que
tiene que ver con agentes neurotóxicos y
demás pero claro que hay hay todavía
mucha tela que cortar utilizamos que no
se llegó al final lo que hemos nosotros
logrado hacer es sacar una teoría que no
existía que es muy más cercana a la
realidad entre comillas
ficción no estamos hablando de un arma
desconocida no estamos hablando de la
guerra fría no estamos hablando de
espías de ataques estamos hablando de
hipótesis creíbles
leonardo hay algún mensaje de los
oyentes en mensajes en realidad gustó
lucas y saludos de la cera de melo cerro
largo en uruguay que avergonzó el lugar
hay el síndrome de la habana y sí muy
conocido por muchos tema muy interesante
con el de 73 para la mesa del programa
de hoy miguel rovira y danielle
camporini también están compartiendo la
emisión nosotros muy bien bueno martín
el tiempo pasa como agua entre los dedos
nosotros hiciera zona una versión en
español si lea solamente qué va a pasar
ahora con esta investigación es que hay
un rol que va a seguir jugando los
científicos o ya está el trabajo hecho y
hasta ahí llega vez decide a la
investigación recibe ha publicado un
informe final qué
entregaron ayer entró en el sistema
científica y una manera que los
científicos ponen a disposición de seis
científicos en el mundo sus
investigaciones
me imagino que comienza todo el debate y
las posibles abrir nuevas puertas sí es
decir a ver si uno toma rápidamente
todas las investigaciones que se han
hecho sobre pesticidas en el mundo ya se
sabe que muchos pesticidas generan
problemas graves ha denunciado a
compañías que han sido denunciadas o que
han perdido casos en la justicia con
demandas multimillonarias por
utilización de pesticidas todos sabemos
que los pesticidas muchas veces usan con
agua y que depende la cantidad de agua
que uno le pone y la que te ha producto
que uno pone la intensidad del producto
gente que se ha hecho a sesionar con
cianuro no puso la cantidad necesaria
para suicidarse ahora viene todo un
debate científico lo que ha sido bueno
hasta ahora lo que nosotros hemos visto
en las reacciones por todo el mundo es
que la gente dice la explicación
tiene mucha lógica y tiene muchos
sentidos no explica por qué solamente
canadienses y estadounidenses que
contrataron la misma compañía y solo fue
esa compañía la que asumido las casas de
ambos porque se trabaja muy en unión
canadá ya estados unidos en territorio
como el cubano es que de alguna manera
queda abierta la posibilidad pensar que
hubo una cosa de un ataque deliberado
dirigido a canadienses y estadounidenses
todas esas preguntas quedan pero la
explicación que da house es interesante
y lo que está en el programa nuestro que
es interesante también es ver todas las
etapas incluyendo a quienes consideran a
cuba- culpable y la defensa cubana que
permiten
yo creo hacerse una idea mucho más
concreta mucho más amplia de lo que hay
detrás de toda esta historia yo había
comenzado a decir que justamente en el
servicio de latinoamérica no me ni
servicio latinoamericano mi colega
paloma martínez y yo hicimos una
adaptación de el reportaje en que estaba
en francés y que está en nuestro sitio
internet así que los que quieran visitar
nuestro sitio lo van a lo van a
encontrar ahí y van a tener más detalles
sobre este programa
realizó nuestro colega martín movilla
para la televisión francesa de radio
canadá martín felicitaciones y muchas
gracias a un mensaje aceptado la
invitación desee matar al índice
entonces tienen que seguir investigando
si como todo porque cuando hay tantos
afectados son 40 países involucrados
geopolítica de por medio intereses
económicos políticos etcétera siempre es
importante que la que al final sea una
claridad así que como dijeron los
cubanos esta es una investigación en
curso que no ha llegado al final los
cuales ya dice lo mismo de ayer
retiraron por otras razones
por esa razón así comenzaron las
sanciones y el apretar la ley en su
busto en las sanciones estadounidenses
contra cuba comenzaron con expulsar
digamos que ahora ha quedado de lado
ahora está venezuela de otras razones
pero la primera razón para echar hacia
atrás en lo que había hecho barack obama
fue el supuesto ataque con armas
acústicas contra diplomáticos
estadounidenses en la zona ahora hay que
tener cuidado con la claridad o con la
luz porque demasiado
es como demasiado oscuridad nos impide
ver gracias muchísimas gracias
gracias a los oyentes que tengan muy
buen programa y ojalá que nos vemos en
otra oportunidad
[Risas]
leonardo si menos y nosotros que sí que
dicen nuestros colegas así tenemos acá
más participación es nelson contreras
rincón dice saludos desde barranquilla
colombia y danielle camporini que no se
estaba viendo pero que ahora participó
con un mensaje y se saludos desde munro
y un fuerte abrazo para todo el equipo
para todos así que repetimos la gente
está conecta con nosotros me encanta eso
el top fan que sigue ahí a gustavo lucas
con el firme afán así es que aparte de
que nos ve todos los viernes ya tiene
como un diamante al lado su nombre
arriba su nombre porque resulta ser un
top fun así que agradecemos los saludos
de todas las personas que se conectan
con
la red social con el facebook para ver
la emisión también lo puede hacer por
youtube o la aplicación por nuestro
sitio internet hay numerosas
posibilidades para ver este programa y
de hecho por la aplicación como vamos en
el conteo de los de las descargas sí hay
que no lo tengo en este momento pero te
voy a fijar y gustavo luque dice donde
se puede ver el reportaje original en
francés y en radio en radio canadá
traigo nada está todo el artículo y la
emisión aunque ter allí lo pueden ir a
buscar en un momento debemos y podemos
encontrarlo en él lo que yo puedo hacer
es ponerle el enlace en el reportaje en
español que hicimos directamente esa
aunque en francés también es lo que le
dieran hacerlo y si si lo hizo si
visitan bien también y así que esa es
una buena idea vamos a ver si hacemos
agregarle el link hacia el programa
banquet para que ustedes pueden ir a ver
aquellos que tengan la posibilidad
entender el francés de ir a ver
directamente el programa original claro
que fue una idea que bueno que yo espero
que se vuelva a repetir
qué bueno el esfuerzo de que tantos y
vice en inglés como radio canadá e
internacional en español y radio canadá
en francés pues se unan cada vez esos ya
trabajamos cada uno por nuestro lado
demuestra la importancia que tenía este
tema para canadá y en ese sentido es
obvio para mí que se hagan las tres
lenguas de las américas si a mí lo que
me encanta es que un montón de medios
estadounidenses están retomando esta
información baja como parece que la
versión en español pues ésta es muy
populares en los medios realmente y
seguramente y sobre todo en américa
latina es un tema que concierne a las
relaciones cuba-estados unidos y también
canadá que entró en el tema entonces es
súper muy importante
fantástico y bueno tenemos dos invitadas
más que acaban de unirse con nosotros
aquí en esta mesa de trabajo se trata de
sandra espada
y soledad blanco muy buenas tardes
acérquese un poquito y tomás del micro
no sé por qué a los mejores están lejos
y bueno sandra y soledad ustedes se
trabajan para una organización boliviana
que se llama falta po que que está
asociada a otra asociación canadiense
está que se llama
en humanidad e inclusión y manita e
inclusión en francés bueno queríamos
comencemos por saber que es falta para
que se las redes entonces gracias por
por invitarnos falta pues una
institución boliviana que tiene alcance
nacional en su intervención es una
organización no gubernamental
y tiene la visión de empoderar a hombres
y mujeres dentro de sus de sus procesos
productivos la población en bolivia en
su mayoría es muy vulnerable a la
pobreza
y lo que hace falta es dar asistencia
técnica integral a estas personas que
tienen unidades productivas en el área
rural y urbana para que puedan
empoderarse socioeconómicamente y no
solamente tener un un mejor nivel de
acde acceso a económico sino también una
mejor calidad de vida
estamos hablando de productores
agrícolas perdón sobre todo en el área
rural productores agrícolas pecuarios
apícolas de acuerdo a las
características de cada región en
bolivia es una un país que tiene muchas
regiones con con diversas estructuras de
geografía flora fauna y en el área
urbana estamos hablando de pequeñas
unidades productivas casi de
supervivencia y lo que hace falta pues
permitir dar ese salto cualitativo que
les permita salir de esa instancia de
supervivencia e ingresar a un mercado
más competitivo dentro de estas unidades
productivas se trabaja con grupos más
vulnerables todavía que son personas con
discapacidad
y ahí es donde entramos en la sociedad y
en alianza con hache y
y ellos son los que financian las las
actividades está desarrollando un modelo
de trabajo con estas personas en sus
procesos productivos que todavía se está
piloteando porque las condiciones en
bolivia para las personas con
discapacidad son muy hostiles entonces
estamos acá justamente para aprender
todas las herramientas la metodología y
ver en qué medida se puede adaptar pero
más les puede hablar sandra en el rol de
la pregunta mía es flauta pues va a
buscar esta gente en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad o espera que esta gente
venga a contactar a la institución
tiene muchos proyectos falta pos trabaja
con fondos concurrentes de varias
instancias de cooperación internacional
entonces cada proyecto tiene sus propias
a su propia su propia línea estratégica
de cooperación y nosotros tratamos de
tener modelos que integren todo esto
y depende a qué población querramos
llegar no se convoca o es todo se
trabaja en plataformas múltiples
públicas privadas entonces lo primero
que se hace es la gestión con el actor
con el gobierno local ya se tiene un
convenio marco a nivel nacional y se
hace un acuerdo con el alcalde o con el
gobernador y en función a eso él define
cuál es la población que se va a apoyar
o el rubro productivo que se va a apoyar
dentro de ese rubro productivo está la
gente si si bien la intervención es
centrada en la persona si se trabaja en
función al proceso productivo ese es el
medio puede darnos un ejemplo por
ejemplo cómo están trabajando con las
personas discapacitadas
bien
gracias por la invitación bien nosotros
estamos trabajando con personas con
discapacidad de hace unos 4 o 5 años
entonces la forma de trabajo está
estaba un poco respondiendo a las
necesidades de las personas con
discapacidad
inicialmente trabajábamos tres servicios
uno de formación para personas con disca
discapacidad con la perspectiva de
inserción laboral y otro era de personas
que ya tenían algún nivel de formación
les podríamos hacer la gestión para que
consiguiesen trabajo y el tercer
servicio era fortalecimiento a unidades
productivas de personas con discapacidad
o tutoras de personas con discapacidad
para que se fortalezca su proceso
productivo y hay un crecimiento
económico y también personal en este
momento estamos implementando un nuevo
proyecto que implica que trabajar solo
con personas que tienen unidades
productivas en funcionamiento uno de los
principales problemas de las personas
con discapacidad en nuestro país es las
barreras arquitectónicas
sandy
no hay andenes y las calles son
terribles entonces y ya es difícil el
movilizarse y además costoso entonces
como una estrategia de conciliar lo
laboral con lo familiar en este momento
estamos trabajando en procesos de
comercialización a través del internet
ya sean sensación de sus productos a
través del internet es incipiente
también en nuestro país el tema de
comercio electrónico pero ya así ellos
pueden utilizar utilizar las redes
sociales esto facilitaría que ellos
puedan vender sus productos entonces en
este momento estamos arrancando con los
dos primeros grupos en esta gestión
tenemos previsto hacer tres grupos más y
donde se les está desarrollando
competencias en el tema de herramientas
de la tecnología de tecnología pero
también herramientas de desarrollo
personal competencias de desarrollo
personal esto facilitará para que estas
personas con información con técnicas y
habilidades puedan hacer esta
comercialización
es decir ustedes trabajan como en dos
áreas bastante claras en la formación
por un lado y digo yo y por el otro lado
sabemos que las personas discapacitadas
sufren aunque están formadas sufren de
discriminación tienen muchas
dificultades en encontrar trabajo
entonces hay entre ustedes a jugar un
rol entonces y ahora en especial estamos
trabajando más con el fortalecimiento
unidades productivas porque lo que pasa
con las personas con discapacidad es que
generalmente deciden iniciar un
autoempleo o sea producir ya sea
alimentos confecciones etcétera tejer
entonces esta es la salida laboral que
ellos encuentran y entonces la idea es
que ellos desarrollan mejor sus
competencias para que haya incremento en
ventas y obviamente mejoren la calidad
ahora la otra cosa interesante de esto
estamos trabajando con tu tórax es decir
madres de personas con discapacidad
severa porque ese es el otro elemento
generalmente lo que pasa es que las las
madres se quedan solas con los hijos la
pareja las deja
y entonces ella tiene que conciliar
entre el cuidado de la persona con
discapacidad y hace la parte producir
atento familiar entonces el uso de la
tecnología lo que va a hacer es un poco
conciliar y facilitar este - sandra pero
o sea estamos hablando de la de las
nuevas tecnologías de la tecnología como
es el acceso por ejemplo a internet en
bolivia es caro el acceso todavía al
internet es caro lo que si nosotros
hemos previsto no les podemos dar
equipos de computación pero sí les hemos
dado dentro del programa un celular
inteligente y es a través de ese celular
en que ellas están desarrollando sus
competencias les hemos dado condiciones
de uso de internet en los espacios de
formación y también ellas se están
aprendiendo a un poco comprar el
internet porque se compraba así por
pedacitos podríamos decir entonces un
poco saber cómo administrarse en tiempos
y costos no
es increíble como sea el nivel también
de formación no es muy alto de las de
las participantes porque en este caso
son todas mujeres pero como ellas
fácilmente se han ido incorporando a
este proceso y desarrollando sus
capacidades ya las encontramos ahí
gazapeando subiendo información
y bueno también ofreciendo sus productos
a través del facebook y ya yéndose a
encontrar para hacer la transacción
constado cómo combinan ustedes la
relación con humanidad e inclusión
nosotros que tenemos un convenio
interinstitucional como decía soledad
nosotros no trabajamos solo siempre
trabajamos de manera multiactoral y en
este caso h y es la que tiene muchísima
experiencia en trabajar con personas con
discapacidad y nosotros tenemos
muchísima experiencia en trabajar en el
desarrollo productivo desarrollo de
formación con producción producción con
formación hacemos esta alianza
y ambas compartimos nuestras
competencias e implementamos el proyecto
ahorita estamos en el financiados por pq
day que es este esta prueba piloto que
estamos ejecutando y bueno trabajamos y
así cuando trabajan con la chiqui como
el del 2014
de hecho aquí en el antiguo nombre de h
y es andy cato interna lo que hace pues
que implica pues el trabajo con
e incluso leonardo hay alguna reacción
de parte de nuestros oyentes y dos
segundos y veedores no es que estaba
tratando porque me hicieron una pregunta
estaba tratando encontrar la respuesta
no encontré ahora sí que en algún
momento les daré la respuesta porque
bueno dice césar rodríguez quien la
escucha desde bogotá gustavo lucas dice
gracias por la información d
la menor la necesidad de agregar el link
para poder ver en francés en el artículo
en francés maría herrera dice saludos
desde san luis argentina y daniel campo
link es interesante el tema se puede
agregar un país de muchísimas y
diferentes maneras hoy las tecnologías
permiten causar daño como como beneficio
y javier gonzález
me hacía esta pregunta es ya padre
leonardo ustedes llevan un control de
cuanto se ha mojado la aplicación porque
yo la bajé desde su inicio así que eso
estaba buscando por no tengo aquí la
aplicación para ver cuántos han bajado
eso justamente estaba haciendo
este programa tiene para mucho rato digo
no no continuo pero cada semana cuando
que están haciendo acá
que están haciendo bueno estamos en una
misión de fortalecimiento institucional
hemos venido a recibir una capacitación
con una institución expert que trabaja
en la temática de personas con
discapacidad e inclusión laboral
y bueno en todo hemos venido a recoger
herramientas de experiencia para que en
función de eso nosotros si ya en nuestro
país hagamos las adaptaciones en función
al contexto porque obviamente es
diferente y posteriormente ver estos
resultados pero además se genera un
espacio de valència e intercambio para
ir a hacer una mejora continua en
nuestras acciones a donde actúen ustedes
en bolivia en qué parte del territorio
estamos como en 35 municipios ahora no
está en tarija tiene que ser en tarija
así pero tienen entre 35 municipios
hemos llegado a tener de una cobertura
de 130 municipios y actualmente el
proyecto trabajan 300 personas pero
bueno a medida que se va reduciendo la
cooperación también y ahorita debemos
ser unos 120
lo que pasa es que son varios proyectos
debemos tener ahora unos 70 municipios
que son contrapartes
son muchos municipios en bolivianos y
son muy chicos
pero hoy es este es el tema de personas
con discapacidad se está ejecutando en
los municipios de la paz y el alto en
áreas urbanas
y hasta hoy
montreal muy hermoso quebec también nos
encantó la visita
[Risas]
necesidades para todos los del sur que
hoy entran en la primavera que sea la
única
estación del año felicitas y no
solicitamos por entrar a limpiar
nosotros estamos entrando oficialmente
botones oficialmente desde hace tres
semanas del otoño bueno si no
aprovechamos inicialmente iban porque ya
comenzó de hecho la le comentaba a
sandra ya soledad que hace dos semanas
hace un frío terrible aquí entonces sí
se han llegado hace dos semanas muy
distinta yo les puedo mostrar no sé si
se ve ahí el otro día tuve la gracia de
encontrarme la puerta de mi auto si se
puede ver en el instagram
una pequeña señal y el mensaje es la voz
de la inevitabilidad porque se viene se
viene se viene si no suena matrix
el sonido la habilidad en la puerta de
mi auto no había ninguna hoja roja más
pero está haciendo propósito en contra
[Risas]
bueno vamos vamos a resaltar los temas
que queremos que nuestros escucha
veedores que están allá del otro lado de
la cámara y del micrófono puedan ir a
nuestro sitio de reset punto sea dicho
sea de paso para que puedan consultarlos
leonora tú en particular nos habla de un
informe muy preocupante de la unicef y
es preocupante dureza es canadá es un
informe que acaba de salir en este en
estos momentos electorales en canadá es
un informe titulado índice canadiense de
bienestar en niños y jóvenes donde
destaca se destaca la importancia de que
todos los canadienses se involucren en
mejorar la calidad de vida de los
jóvenes y la pregunta es cómo y la
respuesta que dio el director de unicef
canadá es votando voten por los partidos
que realmente se preocupan por el
bienestar de los niños de los jóvenes
mirando un poco el pasado las políticas
canadienses hacia estos niños entonces
ellos dicen lo que es el director se
llama
david morley con él hablamos y da una
serie de datos sobre este informe que
ellos analizaron por ejemplo entre esos
datos dice que si bien el 5 y algo
importante el 60 por ciento del informe
se hizo basado en preguntas a los niños
directamente les preguntaban sean
felices y si se sentían respetados
entonces es informes de los niños 55 de
ellos dijeron que tenían un alto nivel
de satisfacción en su vida sin embargo
uno de cada cuatro jóvenes dice que a
veces se acuesta sin cenar sin comer
también eso es preocupante y se está
extendiendo porque antes se hablaba solo
de los niños las primeras naciones
que era frecuente que se fueran a dormir
sin comer en algunas comunidades también
de inmigrantes pero esto se está
extendiendo entonces en ese sentido es
muy preocupante y entonces cuando entro
en el sitio y escuché en la entrevista o
puedan leer un poco el texto hay
propuestas de unicef por donde tiene que
salir solucionarse esto apuntan a
políticas públicas en materia de
desarrollo económico y de educación que
son los dos ejes principales y hay otros
datos muy bien
rcn punto sea para los que quieran
consultar este este informe y el
reportaje la entrevista que hizo leonora
sobre ese tema
leonardo gimeno 9 a ver qué pasa
leonardo tú nos hablas de una
computadora planetaria contra desastres
ambientales en realidad es un proyecto
es un proyecto del doctor lucas copas el
líder de sostenibilidad y sostenibilidad
de la empresa microsoft
el director del medio ambiente de esa
empresa y este hombre sacó un artículo
en una revista importante online donde
habla de la necesidad de tomar el cambio
climático y el desastre ambiental como
una cosa seria como algo que realmente
nos toca a todos y que en realidad el
problema estuvo está presente hace años
lo que realmente llama la atención ahora
es la celeridad con que los efectos
están viendo entonces que los analistas
indican que habría que haber tomado
manos a la obra ayer así que lo que hay
que hacer ahora es realmente lo que se
realizó es gracias de cierto tiempo
exacto es lo que hay que hacer ahora es
convencer y hay que hacer tomar
conciencia a las autoridades a la
sociedad en general a los gobiernos
sobre todo a la gente que tiene el
dinero para hacerlo de generar proyectos
que puedan ayudar como corresponde a
mantener nuestro ambiente como como
debería y este hombre propone una
computadora aguilera de ahí está la
cuestión tecnológica porque dice que ya
hay una por ejemplo un informe una
consultora del reino unido reveló que el
algoritmo aplicado entre gente
artificial podría aumentar el pp y
mundial del 4 x 4 4.4 por ciento y
reducir las emisiones de gas invernadero
o sea que ya hay investigaciones que
dicen que utilizando la tecnología se
puede reducir las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero y al mismo tiempo
hacer crecer la economía qué es lo que
la gente tanto le molesta que los
gobiernos tanto le molesta también
entonces este hombre dice que lo que hay
que hacer es esto llevarlo a nivel
global es decir que hay un todo
y los recursos necesarios todas las
computadoras que puedan ponerse a
funcionar en común para qué
este proyecto de un fin interesante que
es preservar nuestro planeta que es el
único que tenemos por ahora y si no lo
preservamos pues el planeta va a seguir
a veces mucha gente no piensa es que
creen que el planeta que la tierra se va
a acabar no la tierra no se acaban que
es lo que la raza humana
si entonces ahí todos los animalitos
abajo de la miel 30 no no nos dicen que
los todos los todos los vertebrados
invertebrados de menos de 30 centímetros
van a sobrevivir habrá que andar
agachándose pero bueno yo quiero
agradecer antes que se me pase a
nuestros técnicos hoy allá del otro lado
de la piscina a benoit duraban marc
andré de jong y permitir muchísimas
gracias allá a nuestros técnicos y yo
por mi parte el tema que quiero resaltar
es justamente hablábamos de
la adaptación que hicimos del reportaje
de nuestro colega martín movilla que lo
hizo para la televisión o una versión en
francés y nosotros adaptamos esa versión
al español que se puede consultar en
nuestro sitio donde se van a tener un
poco más de detalles uno de los que me
pareció curioso nada más por mencionar a
uno es que estos famosos ataques
acústicos de los que se hablaba de los
que hablaba de eeuu entre otros
perdón
descubrieron que
el ruido sospechoso que los grillos y la
época de apareamiento no en el momento
pensé en las fumigadoras un ruido muy
especial ese podría haber sido el ruido
también también es bueno pero lo que
demuestra el informe es que verán
grillos
se grabaron y finalmente llegaron a la
conclusión de que son el canto de los
grillos
miriam alarcón nos dice muy bien el
programa de hoy me encantó saludos a
todos así que una vez y mientras haya
gente que nos sigue por las redes
sociales bueno pero esto todavía no se
ha acabado
para rato todavía regresamos a nuestras
invitadas de hoy entonces
cuál es el los proyectos para lo
inmediato muy rápidamente porque no se
queda poco tiempo regresar a bolivia
mañana empieza el retorno de tres días
que se llevan de acá
y no estoy hablando de herramientas y
tampoco de ciro durable no se recuerda
nos llevamos la acogida de la gente muy
muy gente muy linda muy acogedora
calidad
también sí
nos llevamos a la verdad yo mandaba las
fotos y me decían están viviendo adentro
de un cuento finalmente
[Música]
todo estaba correcto señor bueno
entonces pues muchísimas gracias a todos
muchísimas gracias a nuestras invitadas
muchas gracias por haberse desplazado
haber desafiado a bandas se han dado
cuenta hay muchos iconos o naranja por
todo hay reparaciones por todos lados
muchas gracias se nos atienda el de una
invitación para que estén nuevamente con
nosotros aquí la semana próxima eso fue
todo por hoy por hoy adiós y hasta la
próxima dios chau